it's not about work or you or Joe it's
about me if I left and I'm with Izzy I
deserve the guilty to be called an ass
but I don't want to be set straight I
don't want you to say the right thing
because the one perfect thing isn't in
Seattle not anymore
[Music]
Wow Wow
well Grey's Anatomy finally revealed
where Alex Karev is and safe to say
literally no one saw this coming
yeah it turns out he's back with Izzie
Stevens
aka Katherine Heigl aka again Jess
Wow oh and they have kids now from that
embryo storyline way back finally she
said yeah I have kids twins and it turns
out they're my kids Mayer this is how
easy and I was supposed to make a baby
so I signed papers saying she could do
whatever she wanted with them and so she
used them and she had twins Eli and
Alexis wild I haven't in years this was
all revealed through letters that Craig
wrote to Meredith Bailey Richard and of
course Jo you know this right here this
cowardice this letter it's officially
the worst thing I've ever done
but it's about me Joe it's not about you
I don't live in my car anymore Jay it's
not what you deserve we deserve and I've
learned so much better than this
oh yeah no this is great they don't want
to hear me say the words
so I'm saying them right now I love you
too a lot it's also true is I'm in love
with Izzie
okay so well I kind of liked that kevin
is he got back together a lot of people
did not and they were very vocal on
Twitter about it in fact these are some
of the tweets quote I thought Owen Hunt
was the worst thing that happened to
Grey's Anatomy but this is so much worse
I will need at least 7 to 10 business
days to recover from this episode toad
texts all I'm saying is if they could
get Justin chambers to come back and do
an Alex Karev at voiceover for this they
sure as hell could have convinced him to
film one more episode with a better
ending than this absurdity so when Joe
left that heartbreaking beautiful
voicemail about how she would jump in
front of a bear for him he was playing
house with Izzie and I accepted when
Shonda killed off Lexie mark and Derek
but this is unacceptable so yeah a lot
of strong feelings the beauty of this
though is that joe is strong AF and we
know this we know
and working fine too following the
episode showrunner Christopher Knopf
gave this statement about Justin's exit
to et quote it is nearly impossible to
say goodbye to Alex Karev for 16 seasons
16 years we have grown up alongside Alex
Karev we have been frustrated by his
limitations and we have been inspired by
his growth and we have come to love him
deeply and to think of him as one of our
very best friends we will miss him
terribly and we will always be grateful
for his impact on our show on our hearts
and on our fans on the world one thing I
have hope on is that maybe they're
setting things up in order to bring back
oh gee characters in the final season
which could be coming sooner than we
think
yes we're starting to think about how
you would end a show this iconic Lea in
their psychotic how do you end it all
right guys that's it for today and let
me know what you thought of perhaps exit
and for all the latest on Grey's stick
with all things eating until next time
I'm Katie Krause hi for now
[Music]